اليوم ايضا احنا راح نتكلم عن موضوع ثاني
مثل ما هذا افرحنا في موضوع وخبر ثاني
كانت النهايه الحزينه لمصور المرتفعات
السعودي
شاب هاني الزهراني اللي شكلت وفاته حقيقه
صدمه لكل المحبين
للقطات المميزه وبالتالي ايضا
هذه
الصور الجميله
انتهت بصوره حزينه ولكن ذكراه جميله اكيد
فعلا عادل يعني حزن كبير غشاء مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وايضا المسؤولين
الحكوميين على راسهم وزير الاعلام السعودي
سلمان الدوسري الذي قدم التعازي لاسره
ومحبي المصور هاني الزهراني الذي توفي اثر
سقوطه من مرتفعات السوداء بمنطقه عسير
اثناء تاديه مهامه في التصوير وقال
الدوسري عبر تغريده عبر موقع تويتر خالص
التعازي لاسره ومحبي المصور المبدع هاني
الزهراني الذي رحل وهو يمارس شغفه في
تصوير مرتفعات السوداء وبعد ان وثق طبيعه
وطننا الغالي بجبالها ووديانها تاركا من
التميز والعطاء طبعا عادل يذكر ان
الزهراني توفي قبل يومين بعد سقوطه من احد
القمم اثناء قيامه بالتصوير وكان اخر ما
التقطته عدساته حبات البرد التي اكتست بها
قمم جبل السوده ونشرها طبعا عبر حسابه في
تويتر طبعا الزهراني يشار الى انه
بصوره المتميزه للطبيعه في انحاء السعوديه
حتى اصبحت صور متداوله عالميا كما كان
محبا للتسلق الاماكن المرتفعه للحصول على
صور جميله ومميزه رحمه الله وخالص التعازي
لاهله ومحبيه وذويه وجميع العاملين في هذا
المجال اللي هم بالاساس زملائنا الله
يرحمه شكرا لعبد الرحمن لعصيمي مراسل
العربيه من الشرقيه يعطيك الف عافيه وشكرا
جزيلا لك
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات